President Biden Mexico for his Three
Amigos Summit after taking heat over his
sanitized trip to the border the big
guys meeting with Mexico's president and
Canada's prime minister Biden trying to
work with Mexico on stopping the flow of
deadly fentanyl that's poisoning
thousands of Americans and he's boasting
about progress at the border but
couldn't even get some basic facts right
all schools discuss our shared security
including our joint action to address
the the plague of fentanyl which has
killed a hundred thousand Americans so
far and how we can attack you know
tackle irregular migration which I think
we're well on our way to doing
by understanding the number of fentanyl
deaths by about a hundred thousand and
remember the scathing letter he got from
Texas governor Greg Abbott turns out
Biden didn't even care enough to read it
the president's well aware of Governor
Abbott's concerns uh and uh what the
essential for us was uh in that letter
uh which uh obviously are in keeping
with the governor's uh concerns and
clearly they don't have the same view
here with respect to how to handle uh
the issue at the border
all right so didn't read the letter and
couldn't even read his own letter that
he was trying to get out there at that
meeting I I think that there was a you
know
I always try to look at things with the
view of what's the good news here what's
the Silver Lining and it's disgusting
yeah that's I really have been a
disappointment to everybody but in
regards to this three Amigo Summit you
think okay well maybe now something can
get done he's got the president has the
midterm behind him he's got the
re-election in front of him maybe he'll
want to really address this and the fact
that they could be so dismissive of a
governor of a state who actually is on
the front lines dealing with this doing
with State money with his State taxpayer
money having to do what the federal
government should be doing and he writes
a letter to the president I understand
it's a little bit of a prop right but
the message in there was here sir I need
you to hear me I want you I think that
is actually pretty rude to take the
letter and then to have the spokesperson
say yeah I didn't read it he basically
knows what's in it no actually maybe
take a moment to read it and sometimes I
think about why do you even want to run
for office why do you want to be in
leadership
partly you want to be in leadership
because you want to solve problems
solving problems means admitting there's
a problem understanding the problem and
now that they've done the check the box
exercise at the border I think Jessica
yesterday said well the Republicans are
moving the goal post they said why don't
you go to the border and now we're
saying well yeah but okay we know that
the Border visit was sanitized he didn't
even talk to the congressman from the
area who's a republican who's a very
pretty reasonable guy he's like willing
to work with the administration on
things he's the only Republican that
voted against the house Republican rules
package Tony Gonzalez and
you just get have a feeling that
nothing's going to change from this
visit I did think one thing that the
president did was was good I would maybe
have liked to see it a little bit more
yesterday the president of Mexico had
the nerve to say that the United States
has done nothing for Latin America and
South America since JFK
and thankfully President Biden did push
back on that because American taxpayers
have done a lot one of the big problems
is when you talk about root causes no
one in Mexico or Latin America tends to
have a mirror I guess because the root
causes of staring at them right in the
face not the mirror you use yeah and you
give Mexico the money and then the money
goes poof and all of a sudden the
cartels have half of it poof it is you
know
Biden wants the job he doesn't want the
work it's always been about the perks
the benefits and the status The Aviator
glasses the bomber jacket patting people
on the back he's the Eternal consultant
that gets the six or seven figures but
never does any work and we also know why
Joe finally brought up fan notes because
Hunter finally ran out
oh classic and uh but who the question
is who's more who is really more corrupt
who's really a more selfish politician
the guy who wanted to build a wall at
the border or the one who wants to build
a wall around his beach house at least
Trump was getting Mexicans to pay for it
where Biden will just get Mexicans to
build it but we're going to pay for it
and the reason he's building the wall
isn't even for security it's to keep Joe
from wandering off into traffic
you are on fire today classic thank you
your thoughts on this I mean it hasn't
been a smooth trip
um so it's not been a smooth trip I'm
not as bothered by him not reading
Abbott's letter what I what I'm probably
a little more bothered by I would have
thought at this Summit we've laid out
elements for what a plan could look like
fentanyl the the trafficking of drugs
and and humans uh be it sex trafficking
be it uh gangs uh coming across that's
what I want answers to and I would I
would have I would have thought and
maybe there's a lot going on that we're
not seeing I too like Dana I'm glad
there was pushback I'm one who has
called for some hemispheric more
hemispheric investment but I thought the
way the president I think was the
Mexican president presented Not only was
was was not factual uh but it certainly
wasn't partner-like uh and what he was
saying although I think I understand the
thrust of what he was trying to get up
and I'm glad our president responded as
he did we need a wall Democrats build it
Republicans agree to what we have to do
on the other side as it relates to
transparency around how you get the
citizenship give us certainty for
students for workers those who have
spent uh tens of at five 10 15 20 years
in America and are looking to become
citizens let's figure out some some
negotiation here but it has to start
with with I think two people at the top
President Biden and I think it right
below him speaker McCarthy they are in
the majority the two of them need to
push one another if Republicans in the
house put forward I think a sound
reasonable and forceful immigration and
Border plan you're going to force the
president you'll have Democrats like me
saying we have to counter I think you'll
have a lot more Democrats including the
ones uh who were with the president uh
yesterday at the border I don't know if
I see immigration reform coming out of
this Congress and this presidency uh I'm
not so sure it would but I wanna I wanna
talk about a couple of things number one
do you recall that the president gave
Kamala Harris the job of being the
borders are and finding the root causes
now he could have he could have fine
lined that fine-tuned it and just said
can I talk to someone coming across the
border I want to know what the root
causes are why these people are coming
across he didn't speak to any of the
people who were crossing the border he
could have found out and gotten rid of
that whole issue right off the bat
that's number one number two didn't take
any Republicans whether it's Gonzalez or
anyone else what what is the problem
with Mr Unity bringing people who are
Republicans with him from that area to
look at the border what's he afraid of
they're going to say something and the
most rude condescending thing he did
there is a man Governor Abbott in a
wheelchair handing up a letter and the
president and Kirby are saying we're
well aware of their concerns we don't
have to read it he's the president he
has to read that letter this man is the
chief executive of the State of Texas
and you know this trip is supposedly
about trade and energy and all this
stuff the most important thing is
National Security and nobody has a plan
right for the the the entrance of all of
these drugs he doesn't even know how
many drugs are coming in he didn't even
mention the word fentanyl for I think a
year and a half didn't even come off of
Biden's lips but the truth is that that
with all of these gotaways 78 000 in
like the last couple of months we don't
know who's on a terrorist list we don't
know who's part of the cartels we don't
know who's building the artery that
they're using to to funnel all these
drugs through and Mexico is corrupt I'm
sorry The Mexican government is corrupt
they're not going to fight the cartels
and yet we think we're going to have
some real agreement with them to fight
the cartels no they're going to destroy
us all right and the Three Amigos are
supposed to be taking questions any
moment we'll have that for you guys you
don't think it's right for the
Republicans to I just want to make sure
you said you didn't think it was right I
don't think the Senate under Schumer is
going to take it up so does that mean
McCarthy shouldn't even propose it
they'll put it out and it'll die in the
Senate I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now